surprise surprise another week in
esports and another cheating scandal to
talk about
in the middle of it all is ninja whose
team allegedly accused another team of
cheating
after losing to them in a recent
valorant tournament the team that was
accused of cheating got disqualified
which pissed people off
but then that decision was reversed
which pissed even more people off
and generally people were pissed off at
ninja and his team for allegedly making
the accusations in the first place
yeah this one's a mess
[Music]
all right guys before we get into it i
need to tell you about the demacia
championship we are hosting the english
language stream
all week live over at our twitch channel
twitch.tv slash the score
esports so give it a follow so you know
exactly
when we go live with that sweet sweet
league of legends action
alright so the valerian tournament that
we're talking about is the nights before
christmas invitational
hosted by the aptly named pittsburgh
knights
now this wasn't a tournament on the same
level as the first strike finals
but with ninja's team named time in and
the likes of nrg
dignitas and genji all competing there
were some notable names involved
but today we're talking about built by
gamers or
bbg as i'll be referring to them from
now on they're a lesser known team that
was also competing in the tournament
see bbg wiped the floor with ninja's
team
beating them two nothing in the opening
round of the playoffs and knocking them
out of the tournament
after that win a clip started
circulating online
allegedly showing that critical a player
on bbg
cheated more specifically that he
aim-locked onto a player through a wall
but instead critical player wants to
just go for the save
doesn't realize it's not not worth the
effort keep that weapon into the next
round
allow time in to pick things up so
that's going to be putting time in with
an eighth round
slowly and surely we go
slow and steady wins the race and that's
gonna be
what bbg are aiming for okay we'll save
this vandal
soon after that the pittsburgh knights
released a statement on twitter saying
that bbg were disqualified from the
tournament
due to quote an ongoing investigation
and that ninja's team would be moving
forward to face gen g in the
quarter-finals
quick aside before we move on how do you
disqualify someone during an
ongoing investigation ongoing implies
that you haven't finished the
investigation
if you haven't finished the
investigation how can you find somebody
guilty of cheating
that makes absolutely no sense to me
anyway
after the announcement was made rob whiz
another player for bbg
released a twitlonger alleging that it
was ninja's team who made the cheating
accusations against them
the twitlonger also talks about
critical's history with cheating
allegations which we'll get to in just a
second
he then ends the statement by implying
that ninja used his status as a gigantic
celebrity
to make this ban happen now in the
twitter replies to the knights's
original statement
james o'connor who is the president of
the pittsburgh knights
said that he personally reviewed the
clips in question and suggested to bbg
that they bow out of the tournament
which he says bbg agreed to and this is
important to note
because whiz the player who released the
twitlonger
says that's not what happened at all
whiz said that not only did bbg
as a roster not want to step down from
the tournament but he spoke to bbg
ownership
who also said they didn't agree to step
down
on top of that esports personality
slasher chimed in and said that the only
entity that can decide whether or not
someone cheated is riot games now
ninja and taimin were hit with a bunch
of backlash after it was alleged that
they made those cheating accusations
and it's important to say alleged
because we don't know for sure
whether or not ninja and taiman did make
those accusations
and the backlash got even worse when
ninja justified the accusations based on
the fact that critical has been accused
of cheating in the past
now critical was accused of cheating in
valorem before
three times actually but all
three times he was officially cleared by
riot
so people weren't just pissed off that
ninja allegedly accused some amateur
player of cheating based on some pretty
mundane clips
they were mad because he did it using
information that wasn't even
relevant to the specific situation but
we're not done
because the same day bbg got banned
o'connor who you'll remember is the
president of the pittsburgh knights
reinstated bbg back into the tournament
why because according to him the
anti-cheat police pd
who he brought on board to review the
clips in question
didn't find anything wrong with them now
here's the thing
the anti-cheat police department are
essentially a volunteer
discord group and they've legitimately
caught
hundreds of cheaters reported them to
riot and gotten them banned
hell in the past i've interviewed them
just to get a better understanding of
what cheats are out there
and how they're being abused but and
this is a big
but they are not a recognized governing
body they are not
riot games and only riot has the ability
to make an official call when it comes
to cheating accusations
so if o'connor ninja whoever thought
somebody was cheating
they would have had to take it to riot
and then riot would have made an
official call on this
now of course once o'connor tweeted out
that he was using the anti-cheat police
as a way to verify whether or not
critical was cheating
he got a ton of [ __ ] for it for all of
the reasons i've just mentioned
in the end ninja accepted the ruling and
tweeted out ggs to bbg for winning
but again the problem is is that ninjas
acting like this anti-cheap police are
some sort of accredited body
which they're not honestly i'm not sure
why they were involved at all
the fact that o'connor and the knights
relied on what's essentially a discord
server
to make a call about cheating in an
official tournament
is absurd to me and honestly i don't
care whether or not ninja or his team
pressured the knights into banning bbg
have we learned
nothing from the other recent
controversies just like this one
hell we've made two separate videos on
two separate situations
where players were falsely accused of
cheating were found
innocent by the developers and still
received death threats because of it
like all stories that involve cheating
accusations this one starts with just
one clip
the point is of course maintaining
competitive integrity of a game
is important and of course nobody likes
a cheater
but it's important to go about it in a
way that doesn't create
anger or confusion or have people
pointing fingers at players
accusing them of things they don't even
understand
and think about it if you're a player
are you going to want to compete in a
tournament
where the t.o can make giant career
changing decisions
based on very little evidence the last
thing you want on your mind
going into a match is the thought that
you could be randomly disqualified
for what a popular streamer's word
and some twitch clips no thanks
and only riot has the ability to make an
official call when it comes to cheating
flash frame [ __ ]
i almost had it so if o'connor
ninja who up so if o'connor
ninja whoev holy [ __ ]
well we got our mbor just me freaking
out over these [ __ ] flash frames
jesus [ __ ] christ